I was sort of thinking why has Andrew
been so outspoken on a few recent issues
and then right at the beginning of the
interview you went oh son of Croatian
parents who left communist Yugoslavia
yeah okay I see that now I know what
they're say in the Lo room is a 180 to
what they're saying publicly especially
when it comes to public uh Mantra and
and stuff that the mainst stream is
pushing you can't disagree with that I
got p through a critical race Theory
seminar while I was an NBA player wow
[__] I was I was that guy asking
questions during it which was not very
well receive I lose out on marketing
deals because of this I lose out on on
on making a bit more cash on marketing
and promos and speaking gigs Co like we
just don't not touch it just just in
case someone protests us or gets mad at
us or whatever so I'm going to continue
to speak out on on stuff that's just
utterly
ridiculous
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kissen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is an
NBA champion all the way over from
Australia Andrew Boger welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me I'm
actually an aid listener I've listen to
more than a few of your show so
appreciate you having me on well brother
right back at you I was a huge fan of
the Golden State Warriors when you were
winning the champ Championship there and
playing with some of the greatest
players in the world and uh before we
get into we want to talk to you about
both politics and culture and you know
sport as well uh we wanted to touch on
the sport side so for people who are not
basketball fans briefly tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been your journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to
us yeah um I'm born and raised in
Australia a Croatian immigrant family um
the migrated um left communist
Yugoslavia many many years ago so a
similar story to yourself um and went
over to the US in the Collegiate system
as a young fellow got a scholarship to
the University of Utah went there for a
few years got drafted as the first
number
one uh draft pick number all overall
pick uh in um from Australia ever um so
that was a really thing for our country
and we were't really a basketball Nation
to see where we are now and and then
played in the NBA for 14 years played in
Traer for two years towards the end of
my career and play for the national team
and that's kind of what I'm what was
primarily known for um was was Sport and
basketball yeah absolutely and you you
sort of uh you touched on being the
first D number one draft pick sorry I
haven't had enough coffee this morning
uh you touched on you you kind of
glossed over the fact that you were the
number one Pig that is a huge
achievement I mean the players who have
been the number one draft even Michael
Jordan was in the first number uh picked
first uh that's the kind of level of
honor that it was and you said the first
one from Australia but one thing that
occurs to me Andrew as an Australian you
being an Australian is um Australia
massively outperforms punches above its
weight in so many sports compared to the
size of population so if you think at
the NBA for example there's so many
Aussie players there compared to Britain
which has a much bigger population you
guys are crushing it why do you think
that
is yeah I mean we do re 25 million other
people we have I think we have nine or
10 NBA NBA players from Australia right
now which is just you know per capital
is amazing but we think in the it was
the 80s 7s 60s 70s year we didn't do it
too well at the Olympics and the
government had implement this a uh kind
of a precinct which was called the AIS a
training issue of sport and they they
threw a lot of tax money at hey we're
going to these Olympics we don't want to
come back empty-handed and they invested
in in sport they put a world class faity
in canra which is the nation's capital
where all politicians live and you know
I ended up going there for a year and a
half and it was Sensational it was as a
167 year old I went there taught you
everything about food diet sleep weight
Ro all that kind of stuff that you need
to do outside of your primary training
and they invested a lot of that so there
was swimmers there was water polo there
was volleyball and then to No Surprise
we started doing well at Olympics um now
we're on the other side of that now
we're on the other side of you know that
they they're starting to dry up a lot
that funding now um just because it's
you know topical for politicians to do
that all these these greedy sports stars
you know blah blah blah blah blah and at
times we seen a bit of a dwindling
performance so it'll be intering to see
what happens in this next couple of
years we've got the Olympics of course
in 2032 in Brisbane so hopefully we can
have a good performance but that would
be the biggest change for Australian
sporting landscape as to why I think we
we punch above our weight it's it's a
really interesting point that you've
made and about the investment it's so
important that investment in sport and
in young people Andrew you were very
young when you got traded into the NBA
you started your career in the NBAA you
didn't even finish college at that point
what was that like as a as a young
lad yeah I went I went to the university
Utah first um did an AO in the USA
landed on the plane and just knew who my
coach was because he had the logo on his
jacket um and then when I got drafted in
the NBA two years later I wasn't even to
of legal drinking age in the US so come
on Earth $6 million contract at the time
us and I couldn't couldn't go to the bar
and have a drink so good my teammates
snuck me a few places before I turned
and then and then I halfway through the
season I finally turned 21 so look it
was eye openening I mean my journey I
was a real late developer I was not that
kid that was picked first I was not that
kid that was the man all throughout
junior basketball like you know 11 12 13
14 I had a kind of a tough Journey um a
lot of people said never make it all
that kind of stuff which fueled me which
was great looking back at it I wouldn't
change it for the world and then within
like a threeyear period I went from no
to the number one Peak literally not
exaggerating I went I went you know
about six months before College my on
the on on the world map kind of but the
World Junior Championships and then two
years in college and then I was drafted
so I just happened so quickly that to be
honest with you I didn't know what to
expect because I was I was just soed the
next thing the next thing the next thing
but once you get to the NBA all the
distractions of being a pro off the
coure are probably the hardest
adjustments you know finances money
agents women at times all that kind of
stuff you got a kind of you know
business dealings Shady people you know
fraud attempts uh theft attempts all
that kind of stuff there's a lot that
goes on that people don't understand or
realize and you kind of have to have
your head on a swo I grew up in like a a
lower soci economic area for the most
part and that was huge for me kind of
navigating I knew where not to go I knew
which people to avoid I'm on public bus
oh that guy looks like he's high on
something and I go sit over here so I
felt like that helped me on my later
later Journey once I got finances to try
and make sure that you know my family
could help have wealth for at least the
rest of the time where I'm alive and and
hopefully their kids and their grand
kids Andrew and look comparing it so I I
really enjoy basketball uh Constantin
and I and the rest of the guys went to a
Miami Heat playoff game it was so much
fun we loved it but I'm my my main sport
is football soccer and he's a of the
time you see these young Lads and they
come from the same kind of you know area
as you they signed their big money
contract in the Premier League and they
go absolutely nuts and you can't blame
them so how did you not go insane or did
you go insane and you had a very good
Agent to keep it under reps because I
listened and I read I read statistics
and I knew that you know over 80% of
professional athletes go broke within
five years of retirement I knew that
from from the start I was like I'm not
going to be that guy I worked shoot hard
to get to this point and I knew how hard
it was like our family you know was was
between middle class and lower class my
father ra own business so it depend the
economy was going was how we went he had
his own business and there were times
where I remember you know we were eating
the same meal um in a big pot for for
five straight days you know like
reheating it reheating it reheating it
and then there were tiles where we were
eating out and having pizza like we at
good and bad so I experienced both ends
of it and I just knew how hard my family
worked or parents worked to through on
the table I was like I don't want I
don't want to lose that and squander
that so I always made sure that I was
thinking about you know investing in the
right thing bettering myself financially
you know I took a class balls in the NBA
personal wealth management class at a
University online so just stuff like
that trying to better myself and and
just being in those meetings you know I
remember going my first Finance meeting
with my financial advisor my rookie year
and I had no idea what the hell it was
talking about he's using abbreviations
he's using this yield and this I have no
idea what you're talking about like I
just said all I know is if my money's
not there there's there's a play load of
friends coming over from Australia
they're going to find where it is that's
kind of what
I what I said to him and it bothered me
I was like man I don't I can't really
participate in this in these meetings
with these smart people so I beted
myself and I've done pretty well like
I'm I'm doing okay and I've retired and
I can I canot have to work another day
in my life and I'll be fine well that's
amazing man and one of the things you
mentioned uh earlier was the fact that
there were a lot of people doubting you
and saying you're not going and make it
why was
that look there was a mix of things I I
I was you know a non Ango in main um by
that I mean bot's not a very Australian
name it's not a Smith Dar so I didn't
our family didn't fit in with the in
crowds and Junior sport all that kind of
stuff my father had a lot of issues
growing up English wasn't his first
language and know word of it when he
came over from Croatia at 16 so our
family had a chip on our shoulder as it
is and we're passionate people from the
Balkans generally a very passionate
people
you can say that again yeah in
Australian culture sometimes but that
was a part of it and I just I was always
kind of much to do my own drama I kind
of didn't really I kind of was stuck on
loving Sport and playing Sport and I was
passionate so 12 13 year old if if we're
teammates and you're not playing the
right way as a 30 year old I was going
to go at you as my teammate like hey
pass the ball dude like your teammate
was open pass the ball and other parents
would see that and be kids got attitude
I look at him look at Bly behaved to his
and it was from a point of I want to
play the game the right way it really P
me off you're not playing the game the
right way oh well you know don't be rude
about it no no play the right way so I
got labeled as a kill with attitude
problem you know and I look back at that
time and I'm like I coach kids um now
today and I like kids that have an
attitude problem I like kids that have
have a bit of WTH because I'm like you
know every two or three weeks you might
need to pick them up and put them back
on the Trap because they flow off the
radar once once every now and then I'll
take that every day of the week because
I know I don't have to motivate that kid
every day right i' rather do that than
every day after to come like come on
Jimmy let's go let's work hard man come
on run a bit faster whereas kid this ate
you know once every now and then they
blew up and I always look back and like
it's a coach's job to to figure that out
to figure out the psychology of
different players and no one really
figured that out of me or even attempted
to which was really disappointing but
anyway I I I progressed on and used it
as fuel and like I said I wouldn't Chang
the world I I if I didn't have that
journey of of not fitting and meching
all the best teams as a young fellow I
wouldn't be talking to you
today oh yeah absolutely and that story
actually I think is the story of many
professional sports players that ended
up making it they they had that drive
and passion from a young age not always
recognized do you think that attitude is
partly what made you as successful as
you as you eventually
became yeah there's no doubt I'm no no
doubt about it um I just put a chip on
my shoulder and I I I literally felt
like the whole adage of me against the
world you hear that from everyone but I
I felt like that I really felt like the
world was against me and I probably used
it even more I try to be I'm not going
to be a victim but I'm gonna I'm
mentally I'm gonna say I am a victim so
I can fight even harder um you know
really every day was about that I had to
CH my shoulder every day like ready to
go ready to fight ready to ready amped
up even just basic training sessions I'm
ready ready to go and I think that's
kind of the attitude you have to out I
think you know all the kids that that
were household named at 11 12 13 they
all fizzle out because they don't have
they don't have to Contin to work um as
hard they can kind of just Coast through
and still be the best you know your
early developers and childhoods are
usually those kids that just don't make
it while ever rarely make professional
it's usually kids that are you know beat
it up by all those kids and then
eventually they put more and more effort
in timing and then all of a sudden that
curve intersects and then it just goes
like that right and then you're just
absolutely dominating the talent of kids
and that was kind of my
story and Andrew what percentage of your
success is down to Natural Talent the
your physique and how much of it is down
to mindset and what percentage do you
think is luck as
well look I think I'm I'm obviously very
lucky to have the size um being sful
tall and long and athletic but I will
say this there's a lot of seven Putters
out there that can't even walk in a
straight line right so I still had to
work I still had to put a lot of work in
for I was growing at a rapid rate and
now every time I grew as a young fell I
lost coordination you know all of a
sudden I'm like why am I tripping over
my own feet or why why is this not feel
right because I I just grew three inches
in a month or two inches in a month
right so that was messing me up through
adolescence in puberty I was a super
late developer so I think a lot of it
was work people will say I we you seven
foot but I can I can point you to a lot
of seven Footers I don't play basketball
611 guys all around the world for
college teammates that just didn't make
it to the pros um so I put a lot of time
in a lot of effort and I just love the
game I really I didn't play basketball
because I was tall I played basketball
first and foremost because I loved it I
was tall as a young fellow 9 10 11 12
stopped growing everyone pass me I'm
like well [__] this isn't good for a
basketball
future it's pass me that I had a massive
spurt like 14 to 16 I grew six and a
half seven inches um but I just love the
game I'd watch it on TV whenever it was
on I'd study it I'd print the stat
sheets back in the day off nba.com and
just take them home from school at us
school prins and I just love the game
I've be i' be English class drawing
basketballs on my paper even in high
school that's all I just love it I just
I hated Mondays because I knew Friday
was far away and once you got Wednesday
Thursday Friday oh I've got a basketball
game tonight and then I'm playing all
weekend I was in headen so I really
truly love the game and what is the
difference Andrew between a good player
in the NBA because let's be honest to
get to the NBA I mean you're an anomaly
you most people never get to that Elite
level of sport even the most talented as
we've just acknowledged for whatever
reason but you get players who are good
players at that Elite level but then
there's that level above the Steph
Curry's you know the Kyrie Irvings
Michael Jordans Shaquille O'Neal all of
these people what separates him is it a
physical thing or is there something
else on top of
that I mean Steph's a mix of Steph just
Steph car just has it like he just he's
one of those guys that you know I can
grab let's let's try to throw this pen
in that cup over there and he would just
two or three shots and then got it he's
one of those guys in it gets even just
random dumb stuff that he's never done
before but he also has a work ethic
match with that right so ever rarely
these days you see natural Talent be
that dominant it's not going to be it's
gonna be you're gonna have it but you
also need to mix it in and you see
LeBron's a little bit different just
because he's a physical specimen like
he's athletically physically stronger
than everyone faster than everyone
Steph's just he's one he's a game
changer he's a generational player
that's actually changed game he
definitely his phit what he does and
he's just a great guy as well you know
really good the Warriors just locked out
I mean they got Steph Steph an Clay
Thompson are just both nonon Superstars
like you they're just they still eat
with their teammates which is rare for
Superstars these days they still hang
out on their teammates you know and to
have that he's unbelievable but those
guys are just you know and Kyrie is the
same Kyrie's just got the ball on a
string and just things that he can do
he's a magician so it's fun watching
those guys up close and try to steam and
stop him and how he stop him and I'm
usually the last L of Defense once
they've got through half half the team
on the last guy standing so they would
try to block their sh make it make a
make make a tough shot but what you
learn in that business is you can play
Perfect Defense sometimes it's just
better offense that's right that that's
right and Andrew I want to ask you a
couple of more sporting questions before
we move on to sort of politics and
culture but you mentioned there that
often the superstars now would be sort
of separate from the rest of the
teammates and and stuff like I actually
didn't know that but it's sort of not
that it makes sense I mean it sort of
feels weird but for people who don't
know that you might have somebody who's
making $30 million a year on a team
playing with someone who's making less
than a million dollars a year let's say
um and H how does that how does that
work now how does that feel how what's
it like how do you manage a team of
people where's that level of disparity
in terms of status and wealth and so on
yeah and disparity continues to grow
it's it's probably your max guys are out
of making 50 to 60 a year oh wow the
rookie deal is under a mill right so for
some guys depending on where you drafted
so disparities growing um but it's
that's the challenge the NBA and
professional sports when I mean back in
the 70s and 80s and 90s a head coach's
main priority was schemes What offense
are you running what defense are you
running can you draw plays up quickly
late game that was probably 80% of it I
I would say 20% was was people
management man management I think it's
flipped now I think there's there's not
a lot of schemes that are secrets these
days the copycat League whoever wins
championship teams will try to read tool
like they did and then copy what they're
doing so you're not really running
anything that's super Innovative like
wow look at that play I've never seen
that before we have we're past that so
it's flick now where I've seen coaches
that are Hall of Fame x's and know
coaches x's and know meaning draw up
plays style offensive style of Defense
but they could not they could not
communicate with their players or they
were hard-headed about the way they went
about things that don't last whereas you
can get away with being average at that
that stuff but if you're got a real good
rapport with your players um if you can
kind of relate to them if you're not too
disciplined but you you gotta have a
good balance of all that you know you
take player feedback as well you're
engaging you you'll have a job forever
so it's kind of flipped I think it's
probably gone too much to the player
player side of things I think it's too
player protective now where players no
I'm I'm earning 60 million as a player
let's say I'm I'm a Max guy I'm earning
60 million and we just signed a new
coach but I don't like him and he's
earning five million who you think G get
rid of first like it's it's common sense
right they're going to move the cheaper
um commodity to keep the the big star
happy and that's what we see a lot in
the NBA Andrew when I look at football
and I look at other professional sports
now I'm I'm we're about the same age
when we grew up in the '90s if you look
at you know soccer and if you look at
basketball you had The Talented Maverick
the guy who was a little bit out there
at times but he was brilliant he didn't
play by the rules but he was so talented
that it it didn't really matter and he
was kind of magnetic I I really enjoy
Allan Iverson for example Alan to me was
one of those guys do you think
professional sport has kind of got rid
of that type of guy because it's now so
professional and there's no room for it
or or is there still room for that type
of person oh media love those guys
because they're they're not as they're
not as common as they once were um as
soon as you get someone that's not going
to get into their box and they're not PR
prepped about what they need to say on
things I love those guys because I like
at least that's that's them you know
it's you know it's them right so but
yeah they are they are much rarer
because marketing
money's at stake sponsorships are at
stake you know good press makes you more
money long term you know say the right
thing do the right thing there's a lot
of players that just say and do the
complete opposite of what their ideals
and morals are and I know that for a
fact because I've been around many of
them um and that's our foral reality but
I agree with you I love I love those
heart on your sleeve look everyone can
make a mistake you make the same mistake
over and over it's hard to forgive you
but everyone makes a mistake and we
forgive or we move on right um that's
your depending on on what you've done
obviously but yeah Sports started to
become very watered down and robotic uh
we always laugh here in the Australian
World Football League whenever they
interview they do an interview after a
game um you know how do you things
things went to that yeah you know the
boys did it the boys did well we did it
for the boys it was all about the team
everyone says the same thing you're just
like might as well just play the sound
scene sound CLE after every game you
know whereas there's a few rare rare
ones left that will actually give some
personality and some cheek and some
humor but then the media said oh they
said was sexist or what they said was
this or what they said was that or they
shouldn't have said that or that's
inappropriate and then athletes con of
don't want to do it so you can't you
can't blame them on the other hand right
because they get reprimanded by their
clubs and media for having any ounce of
Personality Andrew final basketball
question uh and this is very much about
your own uh game you were what I would
say an old school Center you'd play
close to the basket here get the
rebounds get the tappins you know all of
that putbacks Etc but the game has
changed now you talk about the way Steph
changed the game by taking the
three-point shot being able to shoot
from further away being able to shoot
threes off the dribble stuff that people
didn't really used to do but the center
game has changed now too where you've
got you know these young kids coming
through who are taller than you and they
can shoot the three they can shoot off
the dribble they can you know it's it's
incredible do are you are you excited by
that or you one of those guys that's
like no they they're ruining the the
beautiful game of you know back to the
basket from six foot away yeah look I
think I think you as an individual you
want to have as much skill much of a
skill set in different facets of the
game as you can because you become a
more water commodity if you're
onedimensional you're easier to guard
and you just of crack rotations M wise
as much I still think there a place for
Big Bly centers at rebound and block
shots uh we saw that in the playoffs I
mean
jokic he has the three ball but but he's
not a three hungry big man like he's not
going to just sit out on the three and
shoot threes all game that's the danger
when you become a big you should play a
living in the pain but it's nice to go
out every now and then but we're seeing
the opposite now these a lot of these
tall guys nice shooting touching up just
living on the three-point line um I I I
find the game a little bit boring in the
NBA um just because everyone runs the
same stuff and has the same scheme so
it's it's basically a game of who could
Co up the most threes and whoever has
the better three point shooting
percentage wins really that's what the
analytics say the more threes you host
up you got a better chance of of winning
a game long term you know game by game
over the course of the season I find
that boring I I really liked you know um
Phil Jackson's triangle versus the
Knicks bruising physical fing hard all
the Pistons versus the Lakers I like
different
sty wi his team likes to run up and down
this team likes to hold on grb we don't
really see that as much anymore in the
NBA game International game we do I
think in our national league here in the
NBL which is FEA FEA League the Euro
league you still see that I think that's
what makes the battles fun because you
got to coach with one wacky wild system
and another one you're like okay David
you know David versus Goliath who's
gonna win whereas the NBA it's kind of
pretty predictable for the most part and
it's also just from a player perspective
I imagine it's much more enjoyable
playing in in a team where the ball
moves as opposed to just F get give get
it to a guy who can shoot the three very
well but anyway moving on hey Francis do
you like side hustles who told you about
that Francis it's an ad I told you never
to mention that in public I avoided jail
time it was only for a bit of well
people all over the world are starting a
side hustle and they're hearing this
sound the sound of Kit [__] the only
sound I heard was sirens this is a
British claw system trying to keep an
honest man down no Francis the sound of
another sale on Shopify the all-in-one
Commerce platform to start run and grow
your business come on Francis play along
otherwise you won't meet the conditions
of your parole Shopify is a Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're
selling jewelry or jigsaw puzzles
Shopify simplify selling online and in
person so you can successfully grow your
business it covers all your sales
channels from a shopfront ready Point of
Sales system to its all-in-one
e-commerce platform shoper even gets you
selling across social media marketplaces
like Facebook Instagram and Tik Tok it's
full of industry-leading tools ready to
ignite your growth Shopify gives you
complete control over your business and
your brand without learning new skills
in design or coding and thanks to 24/7
help and with an extensive Business
course Library Shopify will be there
with you every step of the way just like
the Metropolitan Police with Francis I'm
ignoring that it's time to get serious
about selling and get Shopify today sign
up for A1 per month trial period at
shopify.com
Croatian parents who left communist
Yugoslavia yeah okay I see that now is
that basically what it's about you just
see a lot of the stuff that we talk
about on the show being from that
background then you're just like uh no
this is too far
now yeah I think it's it's exactly that
um I listen I listen to my grandparents
who were you know my grandmother passed
away you know a few years ago now and
grandfather few years before that and
they they migrated from that and talks
them a lot um at times about what they
experienced they didn't even tell me 95%
of what they experienced cuz they
thought it would traumatized me you know
and um they had they had some stuff they
had to deal with they had you know
neighbors taken by they called him the
woodbar woodbar police which was the
Communist police um for as much as just
singing a Croatian song as much as just
you know engaging in in Croatian
nationalism because you w you weren't
allowed to say you were Croatian back
then so I exper I I heard and
experienced that pain from from them um
throughout their child's childhood
they'll constantly try to move and find
employment they went to Germany they
went here they went there and they ended
up settling in Australia and it was it
was a godsent it's a beautiful place to
live and and gave our family a new life
but that that is why where you know our
family in general and croatians in
general are uh stubborn fighting type
people um but then they'll have a dream
with you after you're both battered and
bruised with that kind of people right
you know you throw some punches and then
you'll have some beers um that's kind of
the mentality that I kind of have and
yeah I listen to you know what my
grandmother spoke about and and she was
uh alive during most of this coid stuff
and and um which we'll get into shortly
I'm sure and she was you know she was
there on PTSD was out this stuff she's
like what this this is what I left this
kind of stuff you know she was in a
nursing home at the time you had to
visit her through a bloody a glass
window you couldn't was like caught it
the love window it couldn't go in the
nursing home to touch for you your loved
ones that go through a blade window that
you know and so yeah talking to her
about it she she had some real real
unique experiences linking those the co
era and and the era of of her childhood
tell us more about that Andrew because I
think most people in in Western
countries won't have any idea what
you're really talking about when you say
she was having PTSD and saying she'd
seen it before what did she
mean to the extent of neighbors telling
on neighbors neighbors telling you know
in Australia we had neighbors telling on
neighbors that they put it in in
Victoria at least they put it uh you do
1 hour of exercise a day outside your
house right and I had a friend in
Victoria his neighbor came out and was
like you've already done your 1 hour
exercise today you can't go out again
he's like call the police I don't care
I'm going to do another cuz he had a dog
walk a dog and then you want to take his
baby in the stroller but that kind of
stuff um coming to visit your
grandmother through a love window you
know not being able to eat together in
the nursing home with everyone you've
eaten with for the last you know however
long you've been there can't eat
together anymore got to eat by yourself
in solitary confinement hang on I
remember this you know can't go out
certain times can't go out there oh you
can go out just to get food rations go
get your rations make sure you go back
home so you link all that and people
think you're crazy like you know I was
getting called conspiracy theorist and
all that kind of stuff you're an idiot
you're extreme just like I'm speaking to
someone who would lived in that era
that's saying it not me I'm relaying the
message but people didn't want to hear
that at the time um but there's a lot of
links you can just go on and on and on
and on curfew and and this and that and
government's always right the
government's got your best interest we
we we care for your health we have your
best interest in mind we would never do
you wrong you know um and she she heard
that whole Spiel and allbe it at a
different language and and probably
strategically told her a different way
but it all ends up sounding the same
when you've been through it look Andrew
everybody here at trigonometry is a
massive fan of your glorious leader Dan
Andrews uh good guy and very moderate
policy everyone gets triggered he's
being sarcastic right
but I looked at what was happening in
Australia particularly in Victoria I
couldn't believe what I was seeing why
did you go so
demented I have no idea I mean look we
there there's numerous different
theories um one is we had a real
conflict in Australia um where our
governments caused issues for the people
to be you know for the people to always
be kind of wary like oh TR trust the
government but not all the way here
people are like yeah the government's
always where our best interest in mind
you know and um there was no reason not
to think that and we're very kind of by
the book Nation like you know the
example I'd give you is you could be in
the middle of of a desert and not see
anyone in sight and if there's a
pedestrian Crossing most people he or
push the button and wait for the light
to go again because because a sign on
the side of the road said you got to
push and wait for the wait for it to go
green that's we have arrows and things
everywhere don't park here you can't
stand there you can't do this and people
have been conditioned to that you know
and other example I give is you know our
news has just bombarded us with this
without us even knowing it and and we
grew up you know my father worked you
know 7 till
5536 and I remember my father would come
home from work just before 6 dinner
would be on the table we' watch at 6:00
news in the background while we ate as a
family generally and we ingest whatever
was thr at us right um and then you
think now and you look back you're like
man like could have told us anything
could told us the sky is turning green
and you said it it's true and the
example I give is we had you know we had
water restrictions uh in Victoria when I
was a young fell um we had a bit of a
drought the government put all these
mandates on you can't wash your car in
your driveway you could only water your
garden certain times and blah blah blah
blah blah and I remember my mom the
neighbor was watering their Garden
outside of in a lot of time zone and my
mom's like what's the neighbor doing she
shouldn't be got you know Watering your
garden and I'm going to call to you know
I'm just like listen to yourself like no
like why what does the matter who cares
they want to water they Garden what they
Garden but that's I don't blame my
mother for that it was ingrained it was
ingrained from the TV do dob your
neighbor in if they they're doing
something that's illegal by by the
government you know and can't work your
garden outside of between 88: and 10 in
the morning it's 10 do call Council and
get a fine and and that's a long winded
reason why we we were so extreme with Co
you know and they scared so much people
to to the misery you know like you got
to catch it you're got to do this and
you got to do that and you know we had
we had all kinds of crazy stuff going on
here like you know I couldn't like like
dubing on telling on neighbors you know
like there was a state that was
basically saying if you out in public
even in your car by yourself you got to
wear a Mas like it was just it was
insane it was absolutely insane and I
was thankfully in a place I moved up to
the place called The Go Coast J or up
here for the most most of it and it's a
coastal coastal city small kind of
regional City and people here there's at
least a bit of a balance um of like no
not doing that sorry not doing it like
and you know the beaches were full and
had a few lockdowns and I put a smile on
my face people were like I'm still go to
the beach like there was Surfers that
were like you want to arrest me like
jump in the water come and take me off
my surfboard you know like but then I
went to Melbourne a few times through it
when when when there was like a green
pass where orders were open within our
own country with like every every state
then basically had borders that you
couldn't get in and out of during
whatever color code they they used I'm
sure you use a singar color code red was
extreme yellow was okay and green was
open and I got stuck in Melbourne during
one of the lockdowns and I couldn't
believe it it was it was it was insan
Insanity like I went to the grocery
store to get uh I went and ordered some
takeaway chicken
schnitzel and I was L to melbour a time
so I didn't have tomato sauce with
ketchup in the fridge so I'm like I need
some t s ketchup so I thought I'd just
stop at the grocery store on the way I
didn't have a mask on me I literally
walked in for like 30 seconds and got
abused like dude I'm a big dude right
straight away what actual Abus like
you're putting us all at wrist and I was
just like
wow this was night this is like you know
8:30 9:00 at night empty grocery store
maybe 15 people in their Max you you can
still kill people mate with that yeah
I'm sure you can but I'm not I'm not a
close people person I don't like people
I kind of keep my distance even without
Co I was always a yeah screw the 1.5 I'm
a five meter guy like I'm always kind of
distance because I just like my personal
space and whatever and and just growing
up where I grew up I just like keeping
my space I couldn't believe it and that
was just a small you know little example
of what I experienced I was just like
people and talking to family and friends
how scared they were and oh my God we
can't do this we can't do that we're not
planning a holiday because the
government because of this we can't plan
this we can't do this close kids
playgrounds outoor outdoor kids
playgrounds got closed and I wonder
whatever I saw they actually tap they
actually got the least type tape and
taped up kids playgrounds so when I went
for a war with my kids I'll rip I'll rip
it all down I'm on record I don't care I
was ripping down whenever I saw those
things they they were covering park
benches at parks park benches no City
because of Co I off and fr and been I'm
like you kidding me like and and that
was that was every day here press
conferences from the um the premier Dan
Andrews and a bunch of the Premier here
were like everyone was tuning in to hear
the numbers because they knew that would
correlate to a lockdown can we get to
zero please please sir let's get to zero
so I can go outside and see some sun for
more than an hour and it was it was it
was crazy it was a crazy time looking
back like absolute crazy time it was it
was it was crazy here perhaps not as
much as it was certainly in Victoria you
know I get a very strong
anti-authoritarian vibe from you Andrew
which I really like I mean I think we
we've got the same attitude here um but
I I suppose what I'm hearing out of you
more than that is look being
anti-authoritarian is one thing but so
much of what we were being told and what
we being told to do just didn't make
logical sense that's I think what you
you were talking about there I'm curious
you as a professional athlete did you
just think that the whole attitude we
have to this notion of health is
completely wrong so it's like we've got
a we've got a disease that kills people
who are obese so let's keep everybody in
their homes did that make sense to you
no no I mean I they closed gyms you know
they closed gyms we know sunlight
Vitamin D could only go outside in
Melbourne for one you know an hour a day
or go get your exercise 1 hour a day um
when I was in Melbourne I noticed I
noticed a few things I'm kind of a
stupid
observant person when I'm just about
done stuff but so whenever they would
announce a lockdown so say it'd be
tonight you know it's 8 o'clock here
they have their stupid little press
conference we're locking down tomorrow
9:00 a.m. blah blah blah blah whenever
they announced the lockdown I noticed
I'd go out the grocery store to get food
or whatever do you know what was the
most busiest thing when they announced
the
lockdown
alcohol that's one yes but no fast
drive-throughs right so right around the
corner from where we're staying in
Melbourne there's a KFC and generally
this KFC maybe
has three to four cars in the in the
Drive-Thru um any given time even in
peak hours maybe it'ss to eight or 10
like it's not crazy whenever there was a
lockdown announce this this this
drive-thru was to the to the highway it
was to the highway like you couldn't get
in there you wait wow wait 20 minutes
for f I started to notice this and I'm
just like that can't be good for your
health like people are stressed they
probably like I'm not going to cook I
don't want to go to grocery store
because either I'm scared there's people
there I don't have to get my car in a
Drive-Thru so I'm just going to feed my
family and two kids at bucket of chicken
and fries like hello you know so that
that's one thing I noticed um but there
was just no incentive for for anything
health related it was the only thing
that was going to be healthy for you was
to get to get a needle that was it get
the needle and you'll be healthy you'll
be fine nothing about anything else um
and then the whole conversation around
you're telling me if I'm severely out of
shap I drink alcohol every day I eat my
diet's fast food on on x amount of
pounds or kilos overweight you're
telling me the vaccine is going to save
my life um but it's a guy or a girl
that's severely in shape eats right um
they're not they're G to be they have to
get the the vaccine to live like I just
it it didn't make sense to me I'm like
hang on a second like this doesn't make
sense to me so I kind of spoke out about
it a little bit and asked some questions
and then bang you know media was media
was all over me with that I never once
stated anything against the that my
whole thing was like can we we ask
questions I severely disagree with the
green pass about being able to operate
in everyday life by showing your papers
everywhere you have to go hey look I I
had the I had the needle can I have my
coffee
now strongly disagreed with that so then
obviously got label as and I'm just like
okay that's you want to label me I'm not
gonna I'm not going to push back and the
fact that I didn't push back against the
labels because I was like if you're
going to label me you've lost the
argument um they're really bothering
people and still bother them to this day
even with everything we know today
there's people that still will not admit
that the they were wrong amre on certain
things you made when before we started
this interview you made a very
interesting observation where obviously
you lived in
California and you were comparing
California to Melbourne and you were
saying about you know the the the hyper
progressives who
their attitude is very similar in
Melbourne as it is in California and
that led to certain things happening
let's let's talk about that what did you
notice I just noticed I lived in both
places I I've said many times Victor the
California of Australia without the Sun
yeahor for the most part we don't have
the sun that's the only difference the
policies are very similar um very
socialistic very you know the greater
good and um you know know Victoria's a
very Pro rainbow and trans ideology and
all that kind of stuff very very big in
Victoria very very big um and I don't
know if it's because the further north
you go in Australia it gets sunnier
people are outdoors more swimming this
that Melbourne's a bit more of a colder
City so you're indoors more you're on
Netflix the TV the internet don't know
if it's that but it's it's very very
similar to to California in that aspect
and I just started to notice it I've
lived in both places and it was it was
was very very similar to me so um yeah
just the head scratcher I mean I was I'm
born bred in Melbourne Victoria was get
a retire you know retire there and blw a
beautiful Al and and and lay my roots
there and I ended up getting out because
of it I just didn't want to deal with
that even Co aside I started to notice
these things um that it was just very
very there's there's a group of you know
Progressive Fringe there that dictate
what the state does really through the
government and I I just wasn't a fan of
it didn't want to raise my kids in that
environment and Andrew you you've
obviously um we you are someone who's
retired now but you've been talking
about cultural and political issues
you've been expressing your opinion and
I love to see it I think it's really
important for people like you to speak
up and say what you think and take the
flag that you've had to take but I'm
curious about the principle of it you're
clearly a very very smart guy and there
is a a debate going on particularly with
regards to the NBA where on the one hand
someone like Andis Canter he expresses
his political opinions and his freedom
we've had him on the show uh about
what's happening the Wagers in China and
and speaking up against President
erdogan Etc and he was essentially
forced out of the NBA as a result on and
people say you know quite reasonably
some people will say well look let's
keep politics out of sport except when
BLM happens then it's obviously a
massive wave that that goes through the
NBA and it just seems like there's a
lack of consistency what do you make do
you think athletes like yourself while
you're are playing should be getting
involved in these cultural and political
discussions I mean Kyrie Irving and
other one one of your uh you know
colleagues he got into trouble because
he wasn't vaccinated and he had his
views on that like should should
athletes get involved in these
discussions or should should they just
play the game here's where I stand on I
I stand on with sport if you're in the
game and you're coming off the field or
the court and you're getting interviewed
I think keep it a sport so how you
played I'm not going to go legal rant
after I'm ask that question in your
personal time in your personal forums by
all means go for your life that's for
you to do whatever you want whatever
you're passionate about I think in that
two hours we all as a society you're so
engraining politics and what's going on
here your local your state your federal
World politics Russia Ukraine we're allo
ingrained in every single moment of the
day social media I think the beauty of
sport has always been it's a two to
three hour release to get away from that
now we're bombarded every commercial
break and jerseys and you know people
not standing for the all that kind of
stuff I think it's too much that's my
opinion on it but I think you know if K
or even Andrew Bo wants to be political
once you're outside of that little
bubble and you want to go on your social
forums you want to do you know podcasts
like this by all means I'm I'm all for
it but the biggest thing with the NBA
and the NFL at sporting leagues all
around the world is if it's the right
kind of politics we'll help you promote
it so righte with and and you know if
it's the LM or if it's this or if it's
that all for it but if there's someone
that's got a different view or and has
legitimate reasons for it yeah you know
in his tner I knew as soon as he wore
those shoes he was in some trouble you
know he was obviously getting older um
is he a superstar player no but should
he still be a vet Min guy for another
three or four years of course he should
but the team looks at it like hey this
is going to be a guy paid him two to
three four or five million a year and
he's probably goingon to be a bit of a
distraction we'll just we'll just move
on right that's the way our team would
look at it um whether the NBA tapped
those teams on the shoulders probably so
who knows but it's just it just it just
always bothered me that it was you know
if you're if you're the
mainstream you know agenda that's being
pushed yes we'll hold you up but as soon
as you go against that at all you must
be some sort of IST or is or whatever it
is right and that really bothered me and
I on top of that just just to finish
that on top of that I know like this
isn't something I'm guessing there's a
lot of players in the NBA don't believe
the [__] they're promoting period and
I've been with them Locker to Locker
played with them against them with them
whatever I know what they say in the
locker room is a 180 to what they're
saying publicly like I had teammates
that were super religious really
Conservative Christian religious right
and they're out there you know saying
some things that are completely opposite
to what they they are a locker room with
their families do you blame them who
knows I mean there's there's money to be
made is there's they're trying to feed
their family as that all goes but I draw
the line on you know when you're
preaching to the masses you better be
living the life of your preaching and I
know for a lot of guys that's not that's
not the
case it's really interesting you make
that point because I know it's a
different sport but you're an Aussie so
you'll know this guy it's the case of
Israel Fel who is a devout Christian and
he came out and was honest about what
devout Christians think about gay
people and that wasn't
accepted yeah to go play over the season
back um yes that's the whole thing if
we're going to allow freedom of speech
and and freedom to be whoever you are
well if that's his point of view look as
long as he's not condoning violence or
saying that you know they should be
shuted or stoned or shunn from society I
don't think you know that's not right at
all and that's that's where we draw the
line but it wasn't that he said my
beliefs are marriage is for a man woman
and you have to respect those beliefs
you know that they're his beliefs and he
has a right for right to those beliefs
you don't have to dis agree or disagree
with him but I you know I'm all four
having different points of view there's
many people that I greatly respect that
I disagree with but that's fine that's
that's that's what you're suppos when
you become an a teen a child to a teen
to an adult that's supposed to be an
attribute that you have as an adult
someone disagreed with me that's fine
take a deep breath we have a discussion
about it and you might learn something
from you and vice versa but you can it's
okay to disagree today's society it's
not especially when it comes to public
uh Mantra and and stuff that the
mainstream is pushing you can't disagree
with that and I've being a big own of
that here in Australia even the trans
ideology and there's a big issue here in
Australia with with with men
infiltrating women's sport and women's
spaces and I'll be the advocate for that
for young girls sport because I have
people reaching out to me like that are
like I don't have a voice I'm scared to
say anything but you know my daughter
just got knocked out by a guy in the
under 16's rugby who's playing in the
women's league what can I do about it
I'm trying to help these people and I
feel really bad and and people think I'm
I'm doing this to
some some side side hustle or gain or
whatever it's like well there be those
people some some news I I lose out on
marketing news because of this I lose
out on on on making a bit more cash on
marketing and promos and speaking gigs
people like we just don't touch it just
just in case someone protests us or or
gets mad at us or whatever so I te speak
out on on stuff that's just utterly
ridiculous and would you have been as
vocal Andrew if you were still in the
NBA or were you more kind of you know
career focused at that point where you
were like I just need to do and I need
to be on the court and everything else
is secondary to
that that's a great question I can't I
can't be hypocrite to say that if I was
in the midst of my career and I had that
decision to make I don't know what
decision I would have made I'm
definitely not going to tell you that
yeah I would have been all in screw the
sister The Establishment I can't be
hypocrite and say that um but early on
in my career I I didn't follow politics
at all I didn't follow social issues
till probably year nine or 10 so I had
no idea what was going on the world and
that was I I I I wish I could go back to
that that time where I was that ignorant
the
world it felt like a bit I envy those
people by the way all no you bring up
issues that are like pretty pretty big
issues socially you bring it up to
someone and they have no idea I envy
those people now really people but I
don't know it's a very good question um
I'm in a position where I can do it now
because I don't need anything or need or
want anything from anyone um I could
still be silent and get my net worth of
23x by being silent and just playing the
game but I don't I've got enough right
now right
so in the midst of my career it'd be a
tough decision be a tough decision
either way but I was outspoken
throughout my latest stages of my career
um even when I was still making big
money on certain issues and you can look
at people can look it up online on
different things and uh right wrong
sometimes whatever but I I was out
spoken Against the Grain probably
probably about two3 into my career
especially while social media started
getting a bit more out there I could
actually get my news out there on
certain things and that wasn't as well
appreciated by some and it was
appreciated by by others and that's just
kind of the way things go well Andrew
and that's really the thing isn't it
because I think we we're similar AG
you're a couple of years younger than us
but uh you know we all grew up in a
world where was like you're allowed your
opinion I'm allowed my opinion you can
think I'm a dick I can think you're a
dick for having that particular opinion
we can still be made so we can still go
and have a drink together we can agree
to disagree but weaving the sort of
anti-authoritarian theme into this as
well it sort of feels like almost
everywhere you go now you have to you
are constantly forced to engage with
political ideology of some form so you
mentioned in the NBA they will enforce a
certain certain world view a certain set
of principles you watch a movie it's
infused with all of this stuff you're
being lectured to constantly and if you
don't accept the lecture then you are
the toxic one you are the problematic
one you are the conspiracy theorist you
are the antiva or whatever it is it just
sort of feels like from every angle now
the freedom of the individual to be who
they are even if other people don't like
it is just getting constantly
constrained and we're less free to be
ourselves would you agree with that oh
there no doubt and that's what I'm
trying to instill in my children I got
two children five and six and I'm just
trying stilling them like if you want to
go that way and the whole group's gone
that way but you're passionate about
going that way or you like that route go
that route you know what I mean you
don't have to follow I'm big on not
following the crowd especially at a
young age you know kids are generally
want want to fit in and all that I think
I've got one of them going the right way
kind of let you float off Butterfly if
you has to it um but it's it's tough I
mean go back to your other point about
you know following the doctrine I mean I
was with the team I got put through a
critical race Theory seminar while I was
an NBA player wow yeah I was I was that
guy asking questions during it which was
not very well received you know locker
room NBA players I can tell you that
imagine the color of your skin didn't
help
mate I was I was like I'm not I'm not
takeing [__] you're not telling me I'm
racist just because I was born and not
only that the the it was like you don't
even know my story I'm I'm an immigrant
came from a migrant family to Australia
that fac my father faced heavy racism I
got expelled from his high school for
punching out his P teacher and his
principal for calling him racist
epithets in Australian school as a 15y
old he was out as a 16y old working in
factories I dealt like our family dealt
with it right so you're not going to sit
there and tell me that I'm racist cuz my
skin color so I was I was pushing back
on all that stuff and people look be
like I'm crazy and it kind of ended off
funny I got put like I couldn't believe
it this was before critical race the
kler became a thing this was in 16 so I
kind of really started raring about 7
wow that's early man yeah yeah exactly
and I was like n I'm not I'm not no I'm
not I'm not I disagree with this the
whole video they played trying to
explain all that you know you can be you
can be racist without even knowing it
like I was like not not not buying it
like I think if you're if you're a good
person if you're good to me I don't care
what you look like who you are what
sexuality you are if you're nice I'm
nice you say good morning to me I say
good morning B that's how I treat people
I'm not going to ask you I'm not going
to say good morning to you tell me your
sexuality first or your race or this or
that right and yeah I push back on that
and I still remember to this day it was
it was a very interesting time well I
was going to ask you about that Andrew
because you know this isn't a stereotype
it's a factual observation the NBA is
full of black dudes right I think we can
say that so what how did that go down
with with with your teammates and and
sort of did you start to get a bit of a
bad rep as a result cuz you had a
successful career after 2016 you won
your Championship 2019 I think yeah I
mean some some there some people that
thought I was racist or I was this or I
was that and I got to a point in my
career where I didn't care if you're
going to label me something without
knowing me or talking to me you're the
ignorant like it's know my best friends
still to this day and teammates are are
people from not only other countries but
but African-Americans you know like I
still talk to on a regular basis and
I've had some of my deepest
conversations about these issues
Harrison bars Harrison bar goldf State
Warriors and we we could actually have
these conversations about different
things and I learned some things from
him you know I learned like we had the
conversation about hey like I Arison
like you know I I face some racism
growing up as well like I'm true but he
that he La hey but the difference is you
kind of have to talk till they know
you're from somewhere else mine's just
Visual and I was like wow that's that's
actually pretty Lightning Point you
don't have to say a word and people can
be racist to you so that you know I'm
learning right so we had those
conversations and that's what we should
be you know that's what Society should
be about right we we have great
conversations and yeah but I mean
there's obviously people that are
ignorant and um you know if you're
you're disagreeing with like once again
the state sponsored Mantra or whatever's
in in an NBA locker room I was always
for the most part I'd go logic common
sense and don't agree with that it's how
the guys do that's okay you know I had a
coach that was a little bit religious
for Glen State Warriors he was uh he was
he was a pastor at a church in LA and
whenever we went to LA 90 something per
of the team would go to his church I was
a guy that didn't because I was like I'm
not going to your church just because I
kind of have to um if I want to go I'll
go but I'm not going to go because I
feel guilty about playing time or
fitting into the group I'm not going to
go I was I was one of those guys that
went my own way and did my own teeth
Andrew very quickly moving on I want to
talk to you about mindset
because to achieve that everything that
you've achieved is remarkable what made
you successful when there are other
people who were more physically talented
than you more gifted than you what
separated you from peers who didn't get
as far as you
did um I think that like a love for what
you're doing is very important I think
if you love if you truly love what
you're doing I see kids pushing to
sports cuz their parents want want them
to do it or pushing to things cuz go and
do that job CU it's going to make you
money but they don't have a love for it
it's it's just different it's much more
clunky and hard so I think Love's the
first thing I think just being routine
based I'm very routine I'm OCD on things
or like my organization set out like
this like I have cleaners come clean the
house and I move [__] and I'm like
losing my mind like where hang on a
second I know this was you know so I'm
one of those guys not OCD where it has
to be perfect but I've got an order
about things in my brain you know so I
think being organized and having a
routine is really important I I I had
that as a young fellow you know before
school I train go to school after school
I train come back at home shoot in the
backyard I just have a routine that I
was just getting um used to so once you
become professional it's kind of easy so
they're probably the two biggest things
you need to L A routine you got put the
work in you know everyone says a it's
all about hard work but it really is you
know 10,000 hours I think to master a
craft is that it pretty sure number um
it's 10,000 hours to to master a craft
of whatever you're doing so you know if
you're a young kid and you're 14 and do
the math how much are you spending your
day times out by the how many days in
the year and you know you want to become
professional you got to be hitting that
10,000 Mark closer to your 20s right so
that that's that's what it's all about
and I think put time you know and also
the other thing you our society I think
that that that is is too is failure I
think failure is a huge huge key
ingredient to success you know most
people I don't know exactly your
previous business Journeys or how do you
came to to what you're doing today but
like you have to fail fail is the most
honest brutal way to figure out what
you've done wrong you know your friends
and family AR going to tell you like I
said if you do something wrong they're
not going they're going to tell you
politically correct way or they're
scared to hurt your feelings when you
fail and business goes under you don't
make a team you get cut from the team
you fail a diploma that's it it's brutal
like there's no be all and end all but
the smart people weren't P about that
three years and feel sorry for
themselves and become a victim have a
week where you might have a few too many
drinks and you you're mad at the world
and get out of whiteboard and be like
okay this is what I did and what do I
need to do better to fix that and all
the good A lot of the successful people
in life have failed I think we should
really Embrace fail now there's a
difference if if you're failing doing it
again failing doing it again there's an
issue there like you're doing the same
thing over and over and get the same
result
is obviously a big undying issue but I
think on the general consensus like that
failures tooo I think we need to embrace
that a little bit more just because it's
a really really brutal learning coup for
people and I think that's so important
and it's such an important lesson for
kids and why sport is so important for
kids because it's a safe place for them
to fail you know you play your team you
do your best you lose all right well
what do I learn from this how can I
improve next time yeah and I'm going
through it with my son he's playing so
at the moment and um I'm not worried
about goal scored all I care about his
effort and you know kids look at goal
scored if they've played well that's
they while I scored goals right so he's
playing soer and he's a bigger kid so it
took him a while to catch up to the the
speed and the footwork of of the smaller
more stocking kids which is great but I
I put him in that for that very reason
and you know there's a few games where
he wasn't get the ball past to you know
kids are a little selfish at that age
which is normal uh well they lose and
like you know he's tear it up and one
game he basically you know somewhat quit
you know he struggled for the last 15
minutes of the game and didn't want to
be out there and I did let him play the
next weekend just to let him train uh
didn't let him play in a big carnival
that he was looking forward to
unfortunately was the hardest thing I
did as a par I said you're not playing
in the carnival you need to fix this um
and then we came back to trading and
doing a one-on-one drill and he and he
kicked the goal and hit hit the in the
training drill it hit the the left the
left the post and the right post but V
would have let it be a goal but the
coach was like no goal and he I could
seen you know getting te eyed and about
to shut down and I just yelled you're
antic be head up he came out of the
drill and then by the time he got to the
front of the line again he he calmed
himself and that was the proudest thing
I ever I've ever done I didn't care
about the goal I didn't care about
everything else he self-regulated
himself as a six-year-old got back in
the drill and actually scored a goal so
like I was like man like that's that is
I was so happy with that more than
anything else because I think it's very
important and he's used that failure of
you know the carnival and all that kind
of stuff and and figured out okay I've
had a bad minute I'm not going to let
this turn into a bad five minutes into a
bad day into into two weeks three weeks
four weeks so I'm a constant battle that
with my kids and I think it's a very
important lesson they have to learn no
they have to learn failure they have to
learn missing they have to learn being
SED out they have to learn a coach not
liking him they have to learn how
teacher doesn't like him sometimes
that's life you're going to you have to
deal with that so if you can get that
tool in an early age um data white I
don't know if you saw his interview from
a little while ago he said the kids that
are brought up in that sense to be a
little bit tougher and and gritty
they're going to absolutely ear the Next
Generation once they're once they're
adults because there going to be very
many of those kids well it's funny you
say that because I don't you will know
who it was but I remember reading about
an NBA coach who said you never draft a
player from a house with a two-car
garage uh and that's that sort of like
that grit and determination and drive
and the willingness to to keep going
even though things are difficult I think
that's really what separates in in I'm
sure in sport but also in life generally
it separates people who make it from
people who don't because that's what it
takes um Andrew it's been such a great
interview it's so good to have you
you're such a talented guy I'm really
looking forward to seeing what other
stuff you're going to do with your life
have you you must have other projects
you're working on now and things that
you're looking to
build yeah I play a lot of poke up um
big poke play
so I spent a lot of time playing poker
um really enjoy it just lot the mental
Battle of it um and it's it's a game
that I get lost in with any on in my
life even when I was playing basketball
get to a perfect table you forget about
it so it's a perfect you know hobby for
me so I do a lot of that I got my own
podcast called Rogue boat uh we're in
the process of actually ramping it up
and going video just finished the studio
so getting that all caed up similar to
what you boys out there so hopefully we
can outdo you a little bit uh so doing
that um i' also invested in a in a uh
pro basketball team here in Australia
the Sydney Kings two time Champions
right now going for a street Peak this
coming season so I'm minority owner in
that club and then I double in a bunch
of startups um and kind of venture
capitalist type stuff so I double in in
all walks of life I mean health health
Tech Healthcare fintech um all kinds of
stuff and I kind of enjoy just being
able to take some educated gambl on
different things and uh one just hit
last week thankfully so I got a nice
turn on one so I'm pretty pumped about
that that that a friend of mine Phil
helmouth actually POA Pro Com me into
with himself so doing a bit of that
stuff and just thought a little bit of
everything um strategically didn't want
to have a 9et to5 or have something that
takes my day-to-day grind because I want
to I look I've dropped my kids off to
school my wife and I alternate I pick
them up from school I drive them to
sport I try to be around as much as I
can because you know my parents didn't
have that opportunity to be able to do
that cuz they're working so much so I
want to make sure I'm there as much as I
can have that W to be able to do that
and still be able to you know live live
a very comfortable life
financially well that's awesome man I'm
really excited for you and we'd love to
have you back on the show at some point
we're going to head over to locals uh
for questions from our supporters uh
before we do we always wrap up with the
same question as you know which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be as a
society the one thing we're not talking
about is that we're not talking I think
having an open honest conversations and
Views that are not aligned um I would
love you know I've reached out to people
from my podcast that have different
views to me the the an views are mine
and I always get a rejection for the
most part it's funny it's usually one
side of politics that won't come on and
talk to me um but that's what we need to
do we we need to be able to go back to
having a conversation without getting
our nickas in a Twist and getting all
offended and triggered and all that kind
of stuff so I think and that goes for
both sides it's not just left or right
or it's it's all walks to life you know
um I think having conversations and
learning from each other that's how
human beings evolve for however long you
wanted to think we've me alive um so get
let's get back to that agreed and head
on over to locals guys where we continue
the
conversation what's the one thing do you
think about the NBA or playing in the
NBA that most people don't know but is
actually really
interesting
[Music]